[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
happy Friday happy Friday everybody
welcome to what might be the penultimate
or ultimate Joey and John Luke stream
pin album or no ultimate ghost of it you
think I don't know anyway welcome we
today we are streaming an older game
here kind of yeah well yes it's older
but it's redundant
you might remember it as being one of
the very first fully FMV games full
motion video
the most famous one to be sure yeah for
multiple reasons and it is night trap
night trap we're gonna go this is the
[Music]
2017 remaster that just came out last
week and we're gonna be we're gonna be
playing it here so I was gonna go to the
options first kind of show off what this
thing has so you have room icons
original and revamped I'm not really
sure what that changes though hmm looks
like just possibly resolution yeah so
you got multiple layouts yep the 2017
layout which is like their new layout
then you have 1994 1993 92 92 and I
assume that's the specific versions of
the game I know the game was on like the
3do I know it was alright
the Sega CD I think this is maybe the
Sega CD version I'm not sure which
version is which that'd be interesting
to look up
well it says checking the development of
it it was originally released for Sega
CD right correct yes I believe so I
think that's the Sega CD version there
the 2017 version is covered by her pip
here but right we're gonna pick that one
just to start with yeah it's a little
bit more of that you say a little more
detailed I guess it looks like you're in
the right roll room somebody saying
revamped is harder so let's just go with
that makes sense it's like a arranged
mode and Resident Evil yeah we shuffle
things around so other interesting notes
there is a survivor which it seems like
it's kind of maybe a wave mode just kind
of like see how far you can you can go
yeah and then they have this thing
called the basement
that is like a bunch of cool
behind-the-scenes stuff but
unfortunately most of it is locked so
the theater this is just um you can just
watch the entire game yeah that's the
thing about this game as you'll find out
is if you actually want to watch the
movie in the story you kind of can't do
it at the same time just replying the
game so the game yep because stuff is
going on like in the background of you
like play the game efficiently you
pretty much have no idea what's
happening which is a little little
strange so you have to unlock the game
for that there is a 1995 documentary
that we could actually watch which we'll
probably check out a little bit later
cuz that's pretty rad that they put that
in here so a little preview of it yeah
conversation with director they show
things like timeline we gotta unlock
some alternate endings production images
you got to do specific tasks like Oh get
this person to die this way yeah which
is kind of neat
and then I in this game yeah oh yeah I
know it was I was just like crime scenes
and stuff no no no you're trying to
prevent people from dying this game is
weird Joe you'll find out so this is
like then like the 1982 version of
something like until dawn yeah you know
in roundabout way I guess
and then scene of the crime which is
I've never heard of this the original
never before released prototype of night
trap I don't know if that means to get a
play it or if they're just showing it
that sounds rad you have to get a
perfect for the games to get that which
is nuts that's not happening today
no so we're just gonna start the game
here alright by the way I have watched
all of night trap but I've never
actually played night trap myself so
we'll see how I'm doing let's see oh by
the way I will be monitoring chat yeah
if you have any questions about oh my
god oh you have any questions comments
concerns let me know I'll try to respond
Dana Plato's on this game who's that she
said I'm trying to think of what else
she's been in she's the most significant
actress in this game where's the volume
up a little bit okay yeah this is FMV oh
my god oh
that must have been the best set to
build all the nineties is calling right
here dizzy that says Mad Dog McCree is
better man doc I would love to play the
better video game I saw some gameplay a
bit like this by the way this is like
the best haunted house we've never been
to volume up here we need here this the
students that have been coming up to
work the resort on this side of the lake
have been disappearing right and left
local authorities didn't have a clue
until our surveillance teams tapped into
the winery house right there I taped
everything you just saw what about the
cameras in the traps probably security
we suspect they're using the winery
house as a cover and they're getting
anyone who stumbles onto their scheme
this is Kelly kid young should also be
working inside remember inside man more
about these traps yeah
that's one thing we've got going for us
man the 90s were a great time riding
wasn't we're role he could do Haynes we
have complete control of the cameras and
the traps but who operates that they do
looking at I'm not exactly certain
special operators from control but we
got to work together on this one any
questions
when these guys got the word from her
agents that they're gonna be in a video
game and you you keep your eyes open
we're all depending on he was specially
Kelly she should be there now I'll
switch you over okay now the other thing
about this game is really hard we might
at some point have to pull the guide
okay by the way you'll notice it didn't
tell me what to do like how that do when
he's on on their way oh [ __ ] those are
guys where those hours no those are the
bad guys already I'm messing up I don't
know the buttons can I look up the
buttons I don't know the button layout
[Music]
baby bolts asking as you seem out now
which is out now for no that's not our
guys this is the bad guys so how do we
Nate trap them these colors and yeah X
camera
I can change the colors just kind of
walking around the house not doing much
what does that oh maybe that's the
button to trap maybe Nick coin or Nick
case ein how much is this game jean-luc
is it I believe this is a 2020 oh it's
red green toads green I think it is that
tell me the code okay we're already
messing up and there's no people no
they've just arrived
oh cool yeah I mean so realistic Naughty
Dog has really stepped up there Joey
look at how I play Knight trap
I don't know how to play Knight track
googles someone's that kindness to
untold on yeah this is like the proto
until dawn oh we're we're going into
going in already yeah oh great I don't
want to get word the twist uh if we get
that far
what do the codes even do I think the
colors are related shoes you have to
like be on the right color to activate
the trap-- like the hell is like the
code
these are your lovely new friends from
the shop yeah change the code on the
screen you have to watch the people
talking at the right time to cook work
on food changes right you have to watch
them in the mentioning like the code has
changed oh my god I just wanted I came
here for a sexy sleepover and I'm
getting access code wave rejoicing all
the people danny
megan is messin call me Victor that's
not creepy how much you wanna bet he's
like an undercover like oh I bet person
he's gonna come in at the end and save
them all yeah so here's something we're
watching all this and there's supposed
to be like this is happening and I have
to like
hitting buttons and hitting buttons Joey
hold on like I've already met I did
something I'm sure someone we got him
you know one guy well where they going
okay we'll go back go back to the the
people I'm sure you and the boys can
take care of everything here I
understand good but she's gonna murder
them all good night like this must be
rich what's wrong there's something
about Kelly
mm woman's intuition again monster come
on let's go we don't want to upset the
auger okay okay
choose to choose a color oh yeah that's
what I was wondering if that wouldn't
that changes to red that means that's
what I mean strap them I think Oh
see if you can find another room with
the guys in there Oh someone that's red
that means I can trap them and so you
have to shoot this week's their head
something so they're heading out so
maybe to the Kohen good now no no it's
still blue
I'm still I'm blue right now the Blues
right okay the code hasn't changed so
that's the same for all the rooms in
right oh that was close Wow yeah well
good one of them died oh there's bags
now oh now that videos over so it's
still blue just not near any Nate traps
yeah
that they were called night traps yep
I'm hitting it ah no the code changed
what were they talking about some dude
okay so I'm assuming the alternate way
this is the best part of the game it
turning it up here this is where they
sing the song the night rap song oh my
god she's literally singing the premise
of the game
wait what yeah
[Music]
okay so the song is called make sure
this dog is gone I trap you should
probably be looking for I am not
skipping this Joey
[Music]
hmm okay dance party come on everyone
dance
how much longer till they all get
brutally murdered well probably pretty
soon because you're watching listen to
the plane it's just a distraction
jealous we should probably no no we're
getting through it we're getting through
it put that through the song Power
Rangers I'm the stoic one edge will be
taking up clothes in the background
saying something our problems okay
what look it was your job to protect
Kelly and the rest of those from what
I've just seen the place is being
overrun
you've missed way too many of those
suckers now until you figure out how to
do your job and do it right you're
dismissed
oh boy
okay think about this in real life a guy
who's tasked he's hired by whatever
organization tried to protect these
girls girls we're just sitting there
watching when you're just spying on them
watching them sing dance take off their
clothes what all the while criminals in
the background are just roaming through
it like stealing everything
[Applause]
and then you get dismiss all right we're
gonna go I want to try the alternate uh
UI styles okay and we're gonna try this
again and this time we're gonna actually
try and kill them all because I I knew I
wanted to like get to some of that weird
stuff yeah which one you want to go in
about 94 194 Oh cuz it has a map -
that's actually oh yeah well I guess
guess the the new one also did but pay
attention to
night trap so you can skip some of that
stuff okay your face whoa
[Music]
okay oh it's a mirror okay
you missed a trap on this like zoomed in
yeah so the other ones seems like it has
more like the full video yeah because
this is like what it's like chopped off
to make room for the UI right there nope
I don't have the right code I don't know
if the code is I'll since going way
faster what's the code
what's the code red red nope not red
nobody the code wasn't red cuz I was on
the red code okay it just it's not
yellow Oh God
it was blue last time I remember maybe
so blue is there trapdoor what are these
guys by the way I mean they are human is
blue it's doable okay so blue sweet I'll
just go around that thing I guess okay
raise the volume up a little bit I can't
barely hear this no but you must stop
BAM it's still blue then still blue so
blue okay so we know blues the first one
hey Carly cuz if we don't see actually
yeah something's happening the other one
didn't do that really I don't think it's
like static yeah didn't seem that way oh
what the okay yeah just casually coming
out of my my bookshelf trapdoor yeah and
here the girls so that's the thing like
it's impossible though you have to play
this game multiple times to actually
fully understand the full picture yeah
cuz your soul so many different
storyline it's trial and error because
you don't know when someone's gonna
change the code right
okay not giving me a chance here they're
all were they going
[Music]
gumgum yeah yeah I want this house let's
get this guy so that is there just like
a never-ending stream of bad guys here
seems like it
[Music]
it's an orphan only says you called a
blind man an idiot not good
sunglasses is he blind this that was
entirely I don't think so
got that guy oh it's just to money or
files well there what we already saw
that scene were they got a mouse right
mat gently got me to do stuff I am doing
stuff mat so go back to the okay that
was good I love their little like
weapons if you can even call them that
they're just like yes he has one of
those um yeah there's little like claw
grabbed yeah we have booms got him
fooled so fun fact I don't know if you
know this Joey this game is one of the
games responsible for the creation of
the ESRB yes I know that it was like
what feel like a lot of like that's
that's as far as I know but that's as
much as I know about like the history
behind the game is that it just laid
that was so weird I hit the button to
change to the scene but then no one died
yes this game and Mortal Kombat were the
two games that kind of released as an
example in court and end up creating the
ESRB in the first place uh you know the
scene in this game that they refer to
isn't actually that bad
that's why I wanted I want to beat the
game and get to the trailer things I
just want to watch like the movie yeah
or like the making of stuff oh you can
watch that later yeah hey oh we missed
what he was about
no that was the that was the weird guy
good neighbor yeah
oh no weird get them again yeah
it's still blue we're good for a bit
good hunting yeah so there's like this
layer of like you're not really sure
what's going on and you kind of figure
it out yeah we're gonna be HS Wow
it doesn't in the game okay this is when
they're gonna do the song so we should
probably not you should watch
we won't watch the song oh there's the
goat oh really
yeah if blue didn't work when did he sit
all it was probably doing that see in
the hallway was dang it no Joey the code
has changed dhokli just says what do you
do control so we are controlling
basically the camera we can switch
between different camera codes no yep
okay screen out green string and then
also the trap so anytime a bad guy one
of these guys approaches one of the
traps there's like a little glowing
green bar that will change no Megan's
got the tennis racket she's dancing I
want to watch it Joey you must resist oh
there's the commandos are they the same
like how far are they away from like two
rooms over probably hear her wait look
II don't wait look at her go back to him
walking around
you're up the house can I trap him by
accident oh no oh no oh oh no can I
prevent it this no I think it's like now
it's all up to us oh you think so
[Music]
you don't go in that basement he just
keeps going into that broom it's done
he's on the roof
wait oh they're going up to the kid got
him gum so what is this trap oh I would
like to know who designed this house and
why people are living in it I think it's
their house they so these people Victor
right but weird guy no no no no no the
people who owned this house that family
the family who's talking where they they
invite girls over and then they use the
traps to capture the girls we have taken
over the houses trap system and we are
using it against them guys that's the
premise is I understand you're not under
debt getting it cuz they don't explain
it very well all I know is what the guy
told me in the beginning okay so they're
gonna work with the system but they
haven't they didn't mention code changes
Matt that's giving me crap for letting
that guy die what was your job to
protect Kelly and the rest of those
things but the one of just sleep jobs
being overrun
you've missed way too many of those
suckers what now until you figure out I
did a good job and do it right you're
dismissed
breaking contact thing how did that
happen no no was it because you got the
commando captured maybe let me try the
other girl I won't try everywhere I said
let me judge them Sonic 2 3 fire 2 and
Super Mario Kart came out the same years
this and none of those are as good as
this game and how many look as realistic
as May yeah exactly right
like come on
I saw an old ad for like videogames and
said like something to the effect of
what it looks this real everything else
seems like a cartoon I mean that that's
not it's not wrong okay it was your
charge it was my job I failed I failed
those girls okay look at this one
Wow so once again I just want to lie for
weird how it always starts out yeah we
still have the blue code right yeah yeah
we're on blue it's so it doesn't change
code so click it this games really trial
and error yeah look at that there's like
I happen to get the same time like with
that one okay so switch back yeah try to
like optimize it yeah oh it did I I bet
building the set for this would have
been really fun
[Music]
so no one in this they've only missed
one so far that's pretty good
coughing cat says we had one job and spy
on cuties and we failed no actually we
we succeeded now we did that oneself
yeah you got to balance out taking out
the guys and spying on the Qt so you can
maximize both this house was a lot of
traps like honestly there is there so if
you like dummy wall there's so many
dummy walls and w-4 is like the
stability the house I kind of call into
question only missed one so far I think
you do that the end look at the end when
you you you trap the family my pianist
says the trick is to change the camera
right away after they die well we don't
know if they die laughter they get
trapped oh yeah you want to like the
second you know they're getting trapped
you want it you want to get yeah the
next one they're trying to like pay
attention to the main dialogue well it's
so difficult when you have so many
different conversations going on at the
same time you'll know exactly which one
to pay attention to right
okay so nothing's moving right now I
think this is they're giving us an
opportunity twelve not anymore
to watch this stuff
oh yeah they're gonna go down the stairs
trip doesn't let me get this yeah the
other day and he's gonna go to I don't
know where he goes to
okay got him back to him and you can
watch him still get hit in the corner
there
BAM got him up right yeah okay bookshelf
yeah it's just like the same five guys
are gonna suit I mean how they're
they're like if they just all go at the
same time they can overrun this house
right I just want to watch her face so
is Viktor the dad of one of these I
think Victor's the dad of like so what
yet there's a girl and then a brother
and then like a cousin it was like I
know I'm Meghan Kelley and then that's
it yeah Meghan Kelley slugs girl who's
like our operative Meghan's the girl
with the UM who is singing okay I'm
pretty sure like a Tiffany in there
somewhere
oh yeah follow follow what I think I'm I
think I missed one it looks like I
missed a couple dang that's fine they're
safe at least right getting a perfect
run on this seems hard okay
has it changed to green yet
remember nope still blue some blue so
blue eventually it will change to green
where does
well I think it changed to green
sometime around when they start seeing
yeah
so in chat saying there's technically
multiple game or multiple endings to
this game yeah it's like the Chrono
Trigger of FMV games oh yeah just doom
they really kind of for all
possibilities all your decisions matters
I don't want any part of this I'm out
come back come back get booked I think
that words it made the sound what is
that supposed to happen let's hope so
let's hope that wasn't a glitch oh no
changed lose James says it's like an
episode are you afraid of the dark oh my
god has about the same production
qualities production values as that
okay guys can't open the door apparently
wasting my time
oh this we don't want him to get oh wait
don't capture no no we want to save him
so yeah maybe we just need to help them
now I think I feel like he'll get
captured either way maybe the spot
that's possible he reminds me of yeah
there's something I think you just
escaped mind you have the Chris Redfield
in the live-action intro to resin oh man
it's like around the same time right
yeah well maybe a couple years it's a
good article that actually explains like
how that happened like how they made it
yeah they even maybe just like got a
bunch of like people like in Japan like
could somewhat speak English with the
actor for Jill is like it was like a
high schooler yep like that babe BAM a
kid like this definitely broke the
singing supposed to be happening someone
says don't catch 35 to 40 why it's an
auto game over what does that doesn't
seem right
I mean we've already missed quite a few
somehow we're already on 40 see fine
house had an auto game over
unless we're accidentally trapping other
people I feel like we're doing pretty
well yeah except for the part where the
game broke maybe this is the hard mode I
don't think so yeah that's a problem
though
Fabio says how long he's been playing
this game for 25 years no for the last
25 minutes so can we get some people
lettings now different we get someone to
fix that camera please
[Music]
other man if you miss number 35 to 40
oh no Co changed crap know when they
actually say the code changes
well it's not green anymore
what does that mean I think I think
she's the one who has the scene where
that people criticized is it coming up
no I don't know if it's coming up but
it's like her in this bathroom and she
gets like grabbed but it's like really
not that bad like like what you you
think you think like all man it's like
some really bad scene or something and
it really isn't
I know but I want to watch it's going on
I'll wait there
they're running somewhere this game is
really someone wait some ring the
doorbell
all right wait go back they're all going
downstairs that's the thing like you
want to watch okay apparently the next
guy so are we Orange
nope it's not orange Oh No
who's that that the guy that's the guy
that oh great he dead there turn him to
a Borg I'll hear the dripping sounds
taking his blood I want to know okay
this is probably the one that referring
to
I hope the code is purple hoodie level
over oh yeah
purple stop bar ball it's red or yellow
then right ah [ __ ] they tell you every
coding game play if you pay attention to
word whatever he's supposed to pay
attention to cuz he said you have to
watch scenes yeah this is the scene this
is the scene this is the infamous scene
hey touch you guys this video game
history right here right here this is
the scene that created the ESRB rating
what's the code should I met because
otherwise I'm gonna mess up I don't I
don't know the cub nope no no no no nope
I messed up I don't know the code all
right you're gonna watch the scene all
right guys I tried
[Music]
I don't believe what I just saw those
bloodsuckers just got Lisa and you had a
chance to save it
I put the lives of those girls in your
hands and you screwed up I'm pulling the
plug on you before you do any more
damage
breaking contact all right maybe they're
called the scat Tinky scat team yeah
that's the scene that caused a parent
send enough of an uproar that it was
used in a court case to create our PC
that's the scene yes I cube said so
graphic right it's really no it's really
not that bad I thought it was gonna be a
lot worse than that
I remember reading I was a kid like what
yeah this game like you you have there's
so many possibilities out there to be
like for the reason behind making like
oh all right let's turn the last layout
okay but uh yeah no that it's it's funny
like that there's an infamy around that
scene that you watch now and you're just
like really like that was the thing
that's it
those bloodsuckers oh wow look at this
version okay okay so I feel like we
should be paying as close enough as
close attention as we can to the
conversations
it's harder though how do you supposed
to know like well I mean we know where
most of the traps are that's thing so we
can keep an eye out in the corner like
if we see them walking we can like go
back to last minute like we know that
it's like when they get in front of that
bed that's when we can travel them or
when they get to like right second steps
of the stairwell so this one there it's
not moving so this is actually probably
harder because we can't see any more I
think we just missed one - I like I
think I like the second in third layout
the two middle ones the best the 1994
1993 ones you can actually see movement
on the bottom and you know oh yes right
the should switch to those yeah you know
yeah I'm not I don't like this layout
this layout sucks let's leave here
I think the 2017 layout showed you
either I never seen that so let's go
back to the 1994 layout I think that's
maybe the most the best one
[ __ ] so guys in what Al Capone gaming
says five nights that big brother pretty
much this is sort of five nights at
Freddy's kinda like like a little bit
not quite but is the same sense of like
your man even like hidden cameras are
out the night yeah so yeah we value for
what I think or do we want try the 2017
when I got a 94 one though let's go 17
okay yeah so that one actually has like
the full frame
[Music]
I don't okay that does move yeah cool
it's just a lot smaller for some reason
yeah okay so this gives it a little bit
more context because now you can see
like where you're barely are you in the
in the basement of the house or it does
have a the map and it has a map that's
cool that's not the basement no but
there's there's a water heat readings to
the basement but there's a water heater
right where are you then I don't know oh
I missed one shoot variety messing up
Joey no I missed them apparently Brett
we should just restart we're gonna
restart pretty messed up too much we're
gonna try to make this the perfect right
now we're in it that's not possible you
could look up a.m. if you go to there
are guides and will tell you like
exactly what if we want to have the best
run possible we could do it we can do it
right now all right
oh yeah look it tells us timecode oh my
god how long is this whole thing about
half an hour
alright you wanna do it let's try let's
try it we're gonna try and do a perfect
run here okay so at 13 seconds there's
gonna be two in the downstairs hall okay
sinister alex is the first time they
changed the color is the one where
Victor talks to the boy hey the best and
the curly hair no cares hall one
downstairs so this one right so this
will be the first one yep you got it
okay next is the living room okay wait
there we got 27 seconds all right yeah
so in a couple seconds it's right here
to help go to the bathroom scale right
there yeah all right then stay in the
bathroom there's gonna be another one
coming right out okay all right back to
living room okay this one's coming up in
six seconds yeah here we go
then after this is the kitchen
okay okay kitchen coming up okay really
soon
oh that guy's walking in there he's
walking into the kitchen yep boom nice
entryway
probably here right at one is that the
main door yes okay
got it know that I've never seen no one
we've never done we've never done that
oh so we're gonna be sticking around in
here for a little bit so so because we
can watch some stuff now what's the next
time code we need not quite a remake
it's the same actors as the ones in the
90s remake like hire new past that would
be hilarious
good I don't know if it'd work though I
think it's like it's all because of the
charm of like right looks like from the
90s and like the lack of self-awareness
like they think it's pretty like they're
putting their all into it right like it
would be too you'd have to hire people
don't know about the original me okay
all right entryway the guy on the stairs
okay
it's next hallway one bounces this one
yes five seconds yep come next to the
bedroom okay
got it and then hallway again my god
it's so rapid-fire okay driveway white
shot out yeah don't see that next
hallway upstairs Oh weird Eddie oh you
saw it yeah okay what time coding right
here for sport oh okay yeah it's like if
you get people to do this like nowadays
it's not gonna be like it's gonna be way
more tongue-in-cheek now than it was
before people were so innocent back then
right early I said you find people who
say to have no contacts yeah think about
like one thing I think about is like Tim
and Eric Oh like have so many people who
just like they do not write like they
know exactly what's going on I'm living
room okay yeah exactly the Tim and Eric
they find people who are very genuine
and like unaware right they're just like
they're not actors but they put them in
these roles and it's hilarious because
of it it's really what you need okay so
the living room okay and the code change
is coming
and how do we know the code change
apparently these they say it I don't
know if you actually want to try and
hear it okay living room living room
bedroom right better this oh my what's
going on over there they're yelling at
Eddie about murdering him whoa look
Eddie it's like we're dead he got
another body for his collection okay go
change so that was the code change shoot
so we missed it though okay so go back
to the room no see I don't know the code
oh it says it changed after this code
what what oh [ __ ] was a blue now now
it's green it was blue should go after
this ocker capture dang it we miss okay
let's keep going keep going fine
nope it's not that code it's not that
code Joey we messed up it's all going
downhill perfect for the first 25 ah
dang it
so the codes random it might be
[Music]
but we lost our perfect rhymes a lot of
lot of people to tune a trap after this
still will keep going but we lost our
perfect rhymes that's fine as long as
orange orange right now okay the next
code change we'll have a lot of leeway
so okay but we need to find out when we
can code change okay also what's the
next thing it's all way upstairs
now all the way upstairs yeah so they'll
be there in like 20 seconds okay ten
seconds well you got a we got ten
seconds
what's next okay next one in the kitchen
kitchen a five two goals watch more
that's dancing and singing okay I'll get
back to this okay my next head room
after that in about 20 seconds okay
[Music]
maybe all that guys getting grabbed
right here okay what's not gonna drive
way right away or about 510 seconds 741
his driveway yeah yeah tell me the
timecode 741 driveway and then 751 is
the hallway downstairs bedroom Oh to
this as much as possible that's a
different angle yeah and then the
upstairs hallway in about 10 seconds
scold 14 so you can't watch this whole
song if you wanted it well unless you
likes flip back to it every every time
yeah you got got quick though what's
next downstairs hallway and code change
is coming up dang and then immediately
after the bedroom go back to the living
room and they'll told me the coach
action
so these guys are probably gonna tell us
yeah and so the next code will be in the
living room well he just said the code
sorry but I was worried about was gonna
miss these guys shoot I'm sorry I stay
in the living room living room at least
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm different code
no no cuz it says do not change code yet
she's good after this guy and I miss
this guy so now we have Jinja gun
alright I'm sorry Jay I'm sorry I
panicked I panicked I should have
listened to you okay I read it's not yet
read maybe could be rapes next next one
is hallway upstairs at 10:48 so we got a
lotta fun they're still alive and now we
get the the undressing scene right
Oh No is that Oh ain't no game over is
this one yeah okay
so we're okay for now ten we're gonna
like you know it's not body and you know
I mean sex toy my father collects weird
that's that's not surprising
oh okay we got hallway - coming up
upstairs
like how Kelly keeps looking at the
camera like hey okay you know this is
weird right
please be read please be read mash it
it's not read next one what's the next
one
driveway yellow yellow
okay we're safe we're safe look at
seeing the driveway okay got him hallway
upstairs in about 30 seconds okay watch
the training from the commando this is
kid I don't remember this guy's purpose
is this the one the hallway down all the
way yeah yeah five seconds
there we go BAM got one living room at
12:02 okay Toula - nope he's in hallway
right you're living in this second got
okay the bathroom bathroom seen it okay
well we got the code so we're fine okay
we're coming up on a checkpoint a
checkpoint
really good oh nice don't miss it
[Music]
drop out BAM Thanks
all right go down to the downstairs
hallway unless you want to watch this
she get away when's the dance miss
Holloway 3:16 okay she's just what they
got her anyway okay
she didn't die they didn't suck her
blood I guess not what baby driver here
whoa 3/6 will be off time for this but
weird stuff was happening okay then
immediately after this go to the
entryway okay yeah so this one will be a
code change immediately riot 13 threes
and then change it immediately you got
it why is this one you have to change
immediately be the ones you don't know
okay okay so they probably recorded
multiple things right yes so next one
will be in the living room Decco 57
all right living room for 1415 we'll
have another coat change
oh so here we go again Wow
I'd feel better if we switch the coat
again to green we don't want anyone else
to get control that didn't sound 80-yard
at all it's like every time they do that
in a different direction or like well
they clearly did it in like a different
microphone yeah holy - what this was
here yeah here it says she's talking to
us - just high five
schemes great this poor kid
whoa that was his doing right yeah we're
gonna get back he probably got it from
okay it's coming up all right hallway
downstairs in about like 50 seconds yeah
where the hell did he get that do not
capture Eddie August pretending to be
he's pretending to be one god be careful
and so we can't accidentally capture
look at look watch for his moccasins
yeah right there
oh good call shits going down 58 go back
to the hallway
I can Megan right okay drop them here I
want to hear all this stuff
holy Sh thank you very bossy
we're driveway at 28 damn it's good
scream sixteen 2087 driveway and then
ten seconds after that Sears hallway
- Ryan says these those are very well
step [ __ ] in the dreamer in the
kitchen
all right living room next one fight
hallway just did I miss the living
redress it I just missed it okay we got
the hallway downstairs in ones that
hello
she's the on she's talking to us but we
all thought we might wrap these people
dead the bedroom and this is a game over
if you miss oh shoot still the same code
right yeah some good screens winds at
five oh I want to hear her hallway right
now go this hallway upstairs
when 46 okay then after this go back up
to the bathroom and then after this
capture immediately goes to the down to
upstairs hallway
okay and activate a trap immediately
right here oh wait wow thank you slow
holy [ __ ] driveway ding you got to be on
point with that yeah Ben Bullock we do
have a cheat sheet because it is frickin
impossible to memorize all the traps
like someone just saw but I'm scrap
driveway still Waylon Trevor now we
might have missed I - oh I'm sorry
entryway watch it goes bad VHS tape the
Tracking's off came over if we miss that
one hallway downstairs
whoa really jeez Oh
19:08 okay don't try that don't trap for
the first one wait for the second
opportunity okay
because probably the first trap is Eddie
so let the first pest go okay no trap
her
yeah and that one's all man living room
thank you okay we're next we're next
they closed the entryway whoa what's
going on where is the here aren't you
right yeah he's an AW gives me well know
the odds we work for them like they own
the odds
[Music]
yes we would
boom suck it driver living rooms next
when about like 10 seconds okay or five
seconds sorry 2015 oh boy bedroom
bedroom at 2120 so we get was oh
dialogue right now okay the SWAT teams
going in it went out again it's fine we
have we have a cheat sheet okay all
right this game is seems a little buggy
hopefully they fix that out fix that up
mas fan yeah the game is a lot more than
I imagined
I know it's not great so they can just
kill next the hallway upstairs see there
monologuing right now I want to hear it
bedroom at 22 24 seconds oh yeah they're
vampires the family vampire upstairs
hallway at 2305 2005 I don't think you
understand mr. Martin
control got him with the stair trap
23:05 up next downstairs hallway at
points renew whoa I'm so glad we saw
that
so downstairs hallway in like four
seconds I'm missing all this good okay
go back to the living room
select 35 there's going to be don't trap
Jeff oh shoot
second opportunity it's okay we there's
a check right 13 minutes in yeah okay
okay we're not it's not terrible we
didn't lose that much time oh geez so
sorry I'm so sorry
dang that's a lot of progress though
living room go be a code change here
shoot I'm so sorry
at least we get to go upstairs to the
hallway at least we get to see that high
five again things are getting really
weird around here keep your eyes open
and watch out for the other girls I'll
be back high five
it's so good
all right entryway okay there's like
stuff happening yeah this kid what guns
are having over here wait wait
yeah look at all this look at all this
weird stuff they are vampires right I
ain't realize that they could teleport
what's next
downstairs hallway at 58 we can watch
this up I love this game
whoa dang I call this stuff we missed
it's 58 ya if ya head down this hallway
Code Red I repeat Code Red
I'm upstairs but the girls are all over
the house
wait don't capture oh no I was supposed
to do that ah always because we weren't
watching it damn it
no no no I I saw the button but you said
don't capture and then I what no because
I was leading don't pester the 81 Oh
which we actually didn't watch the first
time or didn't watch this Sun round oh
we didn't miss that up okay how about
ever want to keep going we messed up a
couple times now we just doesn't talk to
you look man we are at 12 12 you want to
give it one more try
oh yeah I want to give one more I want
to see the ending tonight I want to see
it - I want to see I feel bad because we
were really really close I know I messed
up and I feel really bad
okay so where am I going now I feel
better
we switch the code again to read we
don't want anyone else to get control
okay coats not read upstairs hallway for
the high five again yeah I wouldn't see
this as a movie we beat the game you can
once we beat it I I'd be very surprised
that someone do
do that like cut it oh you oh yeah yeah
like to purported I'm pretty sure that's
already on the kid Raygun
Morais you've been hiding that bolt on
okay next the hallway downstairs this is
the one where it with a tee
yes yeah okay yeah as long as I don't
grab my fifteen but if I grab that 58m
dream no that's a quite now
depends
there we go driveway driveway hallway
upstairs
and then after this is the living room
okay
bouncing is always what time 59
okay better get that idea from
oh look at that I didn't see them they
were hatching it down that's cool okay
what time 25 sorry okay neck all the way
upstairs
back to the room about six seconds and
then bathroom after this and then this
is the one where you have to switch
immediately to the hallway a place
that's so tight that's a very tight
window yeah
what next driveway oh and then stay in
the driveway for the next all right
[Music]
today entryway we've all missing all
this and then living room after this
okay which we have to get right got it
man bouncing hallway okay so wait for
the second opportunity it says yeah what
was the point of that Megan what was the
point of that is your hands just waiting
for him
yeah that's super Sneaky of the game
yeah brain room they tell you yeah trap
him okay and then here okay and then
entryway after this at 1956 okay yeah
this game is only half an hour long but
it's like there's our this is like we do
things maybe not ours
there's a lot of stuff going on at the
same time yeah thanks control 2015
oh they're coming in
and then my next bedroom in like a
minute
yeah 2120 what happened to him oh they
shot him we missed it they're just
hungry Jeff and Tony they're downstairs
in the control room someone else is
taking control of the cameras and the
traps upstairs
yeah bedroom at 21 for me yeah please
are you
we're scat special control a tag team
you've got some explaining bad choice
for a name it's a 2120 yeah
we're stuck
after this is the driveway and then the
kitchen okay the edge of the stage me
yeah right
23:05 is the upstairs hallway
23:05 2305 jean-denis which team entity
he should have been one of the guys
after this one is the hallway downstairs
Holly does this and then after this is
the one where you travel through my own
ISTA throwing Andrew - I'm this guy so
be careful don't trap Jeff okay so what
times I want to hit it then so not at 33
but at 35 by the way here
go okay next driveway okay 54
oh we're worried coming down the
homestretch so driveway and then after
this will be the living room and then
after that hold on when go to living
room first and then hallway downstairs
after this and so after this one
immediately switch to the bedroom okay I
can I can see stuff happening when's
this one this one is that 28 oh god okay
bedroom nice and then bathroom after
this at 54 they don't make you change
the code for like after that like half
of the game and then upstairs hallway 25
10 she's all that's left
[Laughter]
this is her house right
whoa the vehicle Oh drop
so that's the original problem that's
probably what it looked like why is that
one in original format I although we did
it and then it place the song again so
if you do get a perfect run yeah you can
apparently you can capture her at the
end that's awesome
[Music]
turning this up
just before my 90s BAE
[Music]
look what Dana Plato's with him I know
she's spitting stuff I just oh what's
your vampire Fang killing point what's
that
[Music]
ashes in different strokes oh she died
from a drug overdose sad
[Music]
put the little damper on the game all
bet
[Music]
Wow
I think we did a bang-up job here cool
glad we had that we look that up I have
no idea how we would be able to get
through no it's not
so I remember we did he did mention that
there's a behind-the-scenes thing here
yes maybe do one just play out the rest
of the cell address installing them
we're gonna go to that and then there's
was it was there one of special features
that we could watch after we beat it did
we enjoy the theater okay
you might have also unlocked some of the
production skills
[Music]
looking up her
Plato's filmography lots of TV shows
[Music]
both oh just one episode though night
trap 25th anniversary edition 25 years
of night drive of this okay theaters no
available man man 7 I know but like
after after that checkpoint we couldn't
saw we could go back and like redo those
we can only get rights we mystic like
you have to be perfect up until that
point yeah let's check out that theater
so is it will just be the the like the
cutscenes from the game that we like
missed I guess and the thing is like
sometimes cutscenes are happening at the
same time I don't know how you I wonder
if it puts it together in a movie or if
you just picking scenes run out Fiat er
oh it says what's all story related
stuff so yeah I get the wait oh so some
of them are cut off is it because we
missed them but anything we had seen we
can watch that means so yeah this is the
problem is is a there's no way to watch
it like in a good order
like in yeah
man yeah I I wish you would have -
something has made a movie version yeah
the 3d o3o version and the Sega CD I'd
like to see someone do this version
these people are crazy it's a wicked
curse wandering about looking for blood
sorry for the augurs I don't think you
understand mr. Martin but you're in
serious trouble
alright I just want to watch him get
thrown from the window here we go
so effortless I mean here's a vampire
this is so cheesy I love it whole dnews
head back just like that
this struggle right here struggles real
scat team okay that's um you don't grab
my desk okay wait he just got hot yeah
oh that's supposed to happen I don't
know how that works we also go to the
behind the scenes so yeah so get both
endings and seemeth to crime to unlock I
don't know what that means
Oh scene with a crime okay that's if you
do the alternate yeah and we have to get
a perfect you're really close to getting
now and that's a bummer the production
image is looks like there's a couple we
could maybe which I'll get bitten by
Sarah L and then get Captain Holly one
we have to do all these like specific
things oh whoa wow I originally pitched
Knight rap as a large mansion the lake
can involve priceless jewels protected
by the way security system you to
protected the opie wanted the house was
away on business and his young daughter
was having a summer party with her
friends when a sec of trained ninjas
very hard to detect in catch broken and
house steal the jewels how that change
to a troop of toothless vampires trying
to get blood from a vineyard house of
unsuspecting children is a much longer
and funny slash Fletcher frustrating a
Hollywood type story so like his his
dream vision of night wrap was like
these robbers I guess just ninja they're
like vampires
toothless vampires in a vineyard wow
that's fun those vampires oh that's the
grip that's cool yeah so they have a
conversation with an interview with the
director which is pretty neat they also
have this documentary that they did in
95
that like shows the behind-the-scenes
this is pretty cool
of course they start with this scene
extremely offensive right cuz they're
talking about shame on you shame on
people that produce that trash it's
child abuse in my judgment whoever cut
this together was really sassy the video
game night trap for the first time it is
a sick disgusting video game in my
judgment guy who boys a whole lot of
video game but it was a joke for a while
then the jokes are getting serious until
a friend of my family's called me and
said hey did you know Captain Kangaroo
came on TV today and said that night
trap with a bad game the danger right I
thinking ruin the subject of the Wow
violent nature that's that's where it
got very fearless I love Catholic well I
mean that's so crazy it was on the front
page of the New York it's like he seems
to get it right he's like hey this was
just like a goober it's like a dumb
video game like it's not you'll nothing
about is somebody who very
[Laughter]
and when we see the new generation of
business it has to be some weird night
trappings like I never understand the
logic of it when people are saying that
I've watched them it was disgusting
child did they play it I guess yeah
that's the thing it's like just don't
get it don't get it
hey you know Dana they took your game
off the market and Elvis the mon-star
moon star systems this lot on twitch
it's you know in any sense they don't
it's not violent it's not gory it's not
anything like that at all the game is to
save the girls that go in for this
lumber party our state of mind about
something weird happened with the audio
on that so it was really how many dogs
can we trap in the house hungry
[Music]
the guy from the New York Times called
me and he said wow this is interesting
yes we don't necessarily watch this
whole thing here but this is Italy I
definitely want to watch that later
because I like that they put in a thing
about the talking about the the
historical context of this game yeah
because I think that's really important
to understand like why is this game so
infamous not just because it's like a
great early example of like video games
yeah and the ridiculousness of them but
also you know it actually like kind of
had a big impact on on video games for
not prizes it shouldn't have right like
of all the games that could have been
you know like kind of attacked I'd this
one didn't deserve it like obviously
like the ones that are actually violent
combat you know you know games like
Grand Theft Auto and manhunt like I'm
not saying that I I necessarily agree
with those people with the the levels
they were going to with that stuff but
those are at least more understandably
justifiable this game is like this games
just a riot this games fun goof
super mega losers asking like wasn't
there a trend to criticize gaming in
general like in 80s and I think that's
kind of true and probably what led to
this because people a lot of people that
time didn't really understand it I think
there's a trend that criticized a lot of
media yes in the nineties very much like
protecting our children kind of movement
going on so yeah like music you know
games movies there's a lot of a lot of
judgment yeah criticism towards stuff
going on watch go full camera here we'll
close out so yeah thanks everyone for
watching this episode of night trap
where we play the whole game out a lot
this was fun yeah I've got to do this
this was actually the last a lot longer
considering that we have to redo it
a couple different times yeah I'm sorry
about that but anyway so we are going to
be closing this out we do stream games
about does stream every hmm weekday at
11:00 a.m. so you can catch a bunch of
different people on different live
streams every every day of the week up
as for us
we'll be back in some capacity some
forum we'll see we'll see you so this is
the final Joe in John Luke Friday
livestream no more of us on Fridays for
now maybe we'll come back some day as
far as game dump goes because uh if you
for those who liked watching game tom
we're not sure when it'll be back but we
would like to try and do that again in
some capacity
yes so keep an eye on that we want to
show the return yes so make sure if you
want to catch any of those streams
follow us on Twitter or Facebook twitch
comm YouTube all those great things and
we will see you guys next time bye Megan
best girl Kelly
[Music]
[Music]